there's a new book that suggests science
holds the key to a successful marriage
marriage ology is the name of the book
the art and science of staying together
looks at what research reveals about how
to build a strong and lasting
relationship according to a 20-17 study
about 50% of American adults are married
and other research found roughly 40 to
50 percent of married couples in the
u.s. eventually divorce we asked some
married people about what makes a happy
marriage their answer it takes more much
more than just love I believe the trait
that makes a successful marriage is
commitment the friendship is most
important sharing the same goals the
same aims always thinking about the
other person in there anything do we
have to agree on it communication trust
the honesty our shared values are super
important about how we've raised our
children patience and a sense of humor
we can laugh together we
everything when we fight takes patience
really take responsibility for whatever
the argument is you also need to respect
the person it's work and you have to
expect that it's going to work it's not
the honeymoon is very brief and then and
then it's life every day and you work
through it that sounds sweet all those
couples we didn't interview any divorce
people it all seems so easy it is not of
course an offer blended Luscombe wrote
marriage ology the art and science of
staying together
Belinda good morning good morning I
wanted to start with this if you're at
home on your couch right now and you are
thinking of leaving your significant
other your answer to those people is
don't not yet why I I you know I have
been writing about family for Time
magazine for about ten years and I get
books every week two books about how to
make happy children how to raise your
children happily probably three books
about how to make yourself happy and I
get maybe one book a year on how to make
your how to have a happy marriage and a
marriage it's it's the only relationship
you really choose and it is so key and
so fundamental to your happiness
why not walk away from it the studies
have shown that the longer that the
people who have long marriages have
happy marriages it's a great Harvard
study that's looked at 80 years so far
and they found that the health of men at
80 is directly correlational to how
happy they were with their marriage at
50 at the same time you tell people
that's the idea of which we've all been
sold and I and I would like to do a
separate segment one day on why we
should teach marriage in high school so
people understand what makes up a good
marriage but you you make a very good
point here you say the the idea of a
soulmate is a myth they're the idea you
cannot find a soulmate the search for a
soulmate is like searching for the only
one pair of trousers that would make you
happy you become a soulmate but you know
II harmony and all the pop love songs
and the movies they suggest that it's
all about I was
anyone till I found you and you
completed me that's not how it happens
you find somebody and you figure out how
to get on with them and you become each
other's soul mate as you as you learn
them as you get better at understanding
them as you get better at loving them
and this is not hard there's such simple
things you can do one of the things that
the research shows that stunned me was
if you just learn to say thank you and
it seems to work in two ways
one the spouse does not feel taken for
granted they feel noticed and seen even
though they're with you every day and
secondly it changes the perspective your
perspective because if you look for
things to thank them for it means that
you can't be taking them for granted and
you can't be resentful or become
contemptuous and contempt is the biggest
problem is a big big big deal breaker I
mean I wish I'd seen your book when I
was younger because I think it's filled
with a lot of very good advice and
things that really resonated with me you
know it was interesting that taper and
says takes communication it takes sense
of humor bla bla bla bla bla but what I
think is so important that you raise is
how you fight all married couples fight
yeah and if they say they're not
fighting they're not telling you the
truth
but it's how you fight that makes a
difference and that's what I thought was
so important contempt is really really
key here yeah it's key and there's some
very simple very simple changes when
you're fighting try to never say you
always or you never cuz then people feel
under attack defend and then get
defensive and then the wheels come off
the bus it's much better to simply start
with I'm having a problem with I find a
difficult win or I like how you said you
should say what I hear you saying is
which is really unrealistic and when
you're in the king of battle right you
say don't don't do it in the car don't
do it when you're hungry don't do it
just before bed schedule I can't do this
now that I can pencil you in but if you
can do it if you do it just before bed
you tend not to resolve that argument
and I think in a fight you have to reach
some form of resolution I think it's
really important not to fight tired or
just we've learned this from toddlers
you know that's when they're going to
have Tantrums right they're tired so go
to bed angry
everything seems much simpler and
clearer in the morning should you put a
fight on hold
right on hold if you say I can't talk
about this right now but I do want to
come back to it and then you have a
history of coming back to it sometimes
it's good to put a file on hold but you
can't just say I can't deal with this
you can't shut it down she put out she's
not only an expert in the book married
28 years 2 months and 11 days weirdly
described a bit like a prison sentence
there how you talk about your husband
you said I guarantee you and I know this
is true no matter how great your
marriage is that will come a day where
no matter what they do it just enrages
you beyond reason that's familiarity for
you and you can't have family without it
all right Belinda let's come thank you
so much the book is marriage ology it's
on sale today